Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Not so long ago, OpenAI has released GPT-2,
an AI that was trained to look at a piece
of text and perform common natural language
processing operations on it, for instance,
answering questions, summarization, and more.
But today, we are going to be laser focused
on only one of these tasks.
And that task is continuation, where we give
an AI a bunch of text and we ask it to continue
it.
However, as these learning algorithms are
quite general by design, here comes the twist
- who said that this can only work for text?
Why not try it on composing music?
So let’s have a look at some results, where
only the first 6 notes were given from a song,
and the AI was asked to continue it.
Love it.
This is a great testament to the power of
general learning algorithms.
As you’ve heard, this works great for a
variety of different genres as well, and not
only that, but it can also create really cool
blends between genres.
Listen as the AI starts out from the first
6 notes of a Chopin piece and transitions
into a pop style with a bunch of different
instruments entering a few seconds in.
And, great news, because if you look here,
we can try our own combinations through an
online demo as well.
On the left side, we can specify and hear
the short input sample, and ask for a variety
of different styles for the continuation.
It is amazing fun, try it, I’ve put a link
in the video description.
I was particularly impressed with this combination.
Really cool.
Now, this algorithm is also not without limitations
as it has difficulties pairing instruments
that either don’t go too well together or
there is lacking training data on how they
should sound together.
The source code is also either already available
as of the publishing of this video, or will
be available soon.
If so, I will come back and update the video
description with the link.
OpenAI has also published an almost two-hour
concert with ton of different genres so make
sure to head to the video description and
check it out yourself!
I think these techniques are either already
so powerful, or will soon be powerful enough
to raise important copyright questions, and
we’ll need plenty of discussions on who
really owns this piece of music.
What do you think?
Let me know in the comments!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!